the actor who's sort of the icon for a
lot of people in in our generation is
Jack Nicholson and you know young actors
and it's just pretty much anyone in the
culture idolizes Jack Nicholson and you
know that was true for you and there's a
story that when you did the crossing
guard you directed your mom in a scene
with Jack Nicholson is that right yeah
what would that I mean I would be first
of all that's your idol with your mom
and you're directing that would it be a
strange situation out imagine I was
giddy that day because it just it felt
like I was playing a practical joke on
both of them and and then the scene jack
has she's complaining to him he plays
the jeweler and in the scene she's
showing him that the ring did that is
that that won't go on her finger is not
a size seven her ring side so she's
complaining complaining and he finally
gets fed up he grabs her hand and he
puts her finger in his mouth too wet to
slick it yeah and then shoves the ring
on and he says see a perfect seven yeah
so my mother who was always kind of
invested in cleanliness yeah she she was
in her trailer getting ready for the
scene with like this FISA hexer FISA
dirt like scrubbing her hands right
right yeah and so she came to set and
very proudly announced to Jack Jack I
want you to know that I've thoroughly
scrubbed my hands they're absolutely
clean he says that's good my you're on
your own with my mouth
[Laughter]
you